Fair is not equal fair does not mean
equal as a matter of fact equal is
unfair when it comes to incomes it comes
to wealth equal is unfair let me give
you a metaphor for that let's pretend
that you are in a math class and you
work your tail off and you do all the
homework and you pass all the tests with
a 100 score and someone else that's not
as bright as you and does not work as
hard as you chooses to not do the
homework and they get a 60 on the test
for the professor to walk back in and be
a socialist and say everybody gets a
hundred because I just don't want
anybody's feelings to be hurt would be
unfair to the person who worked harder
was smarter more diligent better
disciplined it would be unfair to that
person for that test scores to be
equalized
equal is by definition unfair
there are people that are smarter than
me more talented than me in certain
areas that our culture chooses to pay
them it's a choice to pay a musician to
pay an actor or actress to pay a
professional athlete millions and tens
of millions of dollars to entertain us
and I'm a consumer of that I go to
movies I love good music concerts and
buying CDs I've got a lot of friends in
the music business I buy books by
authors that I think are fabulous
writers and I read their books read
everything John Grisham writes and as
far as the adult stuff anyway he writes
a series for kids I'm not going to read
but I you know so if John Grisham gets
rich
by selling me a bunch of books and you a
bunch of books because we all like his
writing he should not be penalized for
that he helped us he entertained us he
lifted us if Tom Cruise or Nicole Kidman
or Brad Paisley or name any other name
in any of them peyton manning archie
manning if any of these people become
wealthy because we choose to pay ticket
prices or purchase products that are
associated with them that's our choice
to do that as a society and they have
obviously provided us some entertainment
they provided us some education some
lift
they've provided our souls some music to
wallow in whatever it is but if if
somebody sells 10 million records or 10
million books and someone else sells two
records or two books it is unfair for
their incomes to be equal well the
little man's not on an even playing
field yeah we are on the even playing
field in the sense that you're all free
in a sense that you get to do whatever
you want to do there are some of us that
have more barriers than others and some
of us have more physical and mental and
actual talent than others but the more
talented has always gotten paid more
than the less talented well that's not
fair yes it is fair it would be unfair
for it to be otherwise why would you
want to watch someone play the violin
who's not good at it versus watching a
virtuoso and paying $200 a ticket for
the opportunity well they ought to give
their their services away for free
says you you see the problem
we've got a bunch of whiners in our
culture a bunch of little wusses the
cult culture has become sissified it's
ridiculous and everybody's afraid
somebody's gonna get their little
feelings hurt everybody's running around
trying to get their little feelings hurt
all the time and that ain't errs into
this political discussion and this
economic discussion of wealth because
most people that are wealthy in North
America statistically about nine out of
ten that are wealthy in America nine out
ten millionaires as an example started
with nothing and became millionaires now
when you get two billionaires it drops
to about seventy percent our first
generation 30% inherited some money but
seven out of ten billionaires started
with nothing like Oprah started with
nothing now if you do a half but local
cable access show you should not get
paid what Oprah gets paid when Oprah was
doing the Oprah show during the week the
woman had a work ethic that would put
most of you people in the hospital and
she's brilliant she's a brilliant
businesswoman she's brilliant on the
camera you may not agree with her you
may not agree with political views I
don't always I got an argument with her
on her own show but that doesn't matter
she's brilliant and she has a work ethic
that's absolutely freakin incredible
she's Oprah she's Mother Nature let's
give it a break here people give it up
for she's awesome and for her to make
more than somebody doing Wayne's World
on community access that's how it works
it would be unfair for your wealth to be
equal with hers she works harder she's
got more talent more business savvy all
in one package and has become a
billionaire starting from literally
nothing and those stories are all over
America so this idea that everybody's
worried about wealth equality well it's
just not fair yes it is you see I was in
Saint Petersburg Russia just a little
while back on a vacation and it was
interesting to me how many capitalists
are in Russia
they're all over the street sell you
anything baby all under than all on the
down-low all the black market it's not
part of the quote aboveboard economy but
capitalism is what happens when you
leave people alone and the person who
hustles and grinds and works and has
more talent will always come out with
more than the person who sits on their
butt and sits around scratching their
ear and says well life's not fair woe is
me you do reap what you sow we do live
in a cause-and-effect universe in
society and that's okay
the Peyton Manning has more money than
me and that Brad Paisley makes more
playing a guitar than I will ever make
because frankly I'm not any good at the
guitar and I'm proud for Brad and I'm
proud for Payton and I'm proud for Oprah
I hope they make even more because I
enjoy the products that they put out so
stop your whining in your envious stuff
America
you